in a nutshell a very bad night for the
two big parties and a very good one for
the Lib Dems but if your choice conclude
this was all about an anti or pro brexit
vote have a look beneath the surface and
you'll see it was a bit more complicated
than that so while the Tories lost
councillors in most places they gained
them in northeast Lincolnshire an area
that voted strongly for brexit taking
control there for the first time ever
and now look at Chelmsford which also
voted leave the Tory vote cratered and
the Lib Dems now have control labour won
Trafford a big metropolitan districts
they haven't held it in 17 years but
they also lost control of bowls over the
territory of veteran MP Denis Skinner 14
seats lost 11 of them to independence
it's the weakest Labor's ever been in
that council as for the Lib Dems the
news was almost entirely positive
winning Tory councils not just in Essex
and East Anglia but across the southwest
places like Bath and North East Somerset
that's Jacob Riis Mark's own backyard so
what would happen if you projected all
of these results to the House of Commons
well according to us to follow just
Michael Thrasher the Tories would end up
with a very similar share of the vote
but convert it into parliamentary seats
and this is what you get 280 seats for
the Tories 268 for labour 28 for the Lib
Dems 53 for the SNP and 21 MPs from
other parties and it would imply guess
what another hung parliament but the
Tories will be so short of an overall
majority the most likely coalition party
would be labour plus the SNP plus maybe
the Lib Dems and I'm not sure that's a
projection that will fill either of the
two big parties with much in the way of
enthusiasm